driving over to Nuggets off the heels  got it back to hood he'll try a 3  Blazers by 2  [Applause]  [Music]  the only guy that's not exhausted has  been the key guy down the stretch  [Applause]  brought the hood at 15  points five of eleven a last game in the  win on the road CJ over two defenders  offensive rebounds his own miss how  about the up fake and poised to stay in  three by mr. hood who also had three  blocks the last game look at him this  isn't somebody who's dunking in the  corner this is I'm out here at three  unrolling  slide by the defender you don't show  discipline I put it down the  acquisitions by Niall O'Shea and Terry  Stotts with hood coming over from  Cleveland